je suis de bonne humeur aujourd'hui je
suis mon entrée en marche en arrière sur
un gangster bon je vous ai demandé sur
twitter de me dire ce que vous voudriez
à être ou qui vous comment vous voudriez
être afin de réaliser votre rêve à
savoir vous transformer comme ça par
exemple si vous rêvez d'être brad pitt
je peux vous faire revenir brad pitt
bien sûr bien sûr à l'aide d'un logiciel
qui s'appelle vegas pro et par photoshop
tout le monde dans le youtube games se
moque de moi parce que je suis le
dernier mec envie à utiliser vegas pro
pour faire ces montages 100 % des gens
sont passés sur adobe premiere pro et
moi je reste dans le passé j'arrive pas
évolué - les tandems plaisanterie alors
elle voudrait être une montgolfière bon
c'est facile on va commencer par trouver
une image merveilleuse de montgolfières
à à temps mais je passe il a peut-être
assez grosse sucette
très bien je viens de passer neuf
minutes essayer de rendre quelqu'un en
montgolfière assez dégueulasse ça me
plaît énormément et je me chauffe là
j'avoue spa ou fait je me chauffe way
j'aimerais qu'on gagne en street cred
eh les mecs c'est chaud là attaché comme
en affaires on va taper gangstas sur
shutterstock bon voilà pas besoin de
faire de photomontages on dirait pivi
nova pical ces bons ne pas me casser les
couilles et ça c'est fait j'ai toujours
rêvé de forme des plats salés dan
szpiner custom de ouf un nom venom et
j'ai renoncé de position ça va pas du
tout il faut pas faire ça bon je vais
réaliser ton rêve alors on va commencer
par t'isoler je suis le seul mec au
monde à détourer à la main tant vos deux
chocs tels outils détour tout seul voilà
bim c'est magique moi je suis là avec ma
[ __ ] de main comme il est dans merde
scandaleux alors maintenant que germain
et isoler et qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
veut de lui de ses le bridge qui germa
et c'est quoi je vais te faire te
déplacer sur ton propre haine szpiner
mon pote
mais voilà on est perfectionniste on
l'est pas après hop je crois je suis pas
sûr que je vais peut-être de jeu que je
viens de réaliser ton rêve
et voilà germain qui s'envole sur saône
szpiner c'est beau ce soir en ouvrant
taft et à 2h du mat parce qu'il commence
à faire hyper chaud tu verra peut-être
noz man passé comme ça dans le ciel on
sait par maxence qui nous dit j'aimerais
bien ressembler à michael jackson et
être sur scène merci [ __ ] les mecs là
on part de loin
bon déjà de base il faut juste isoler
son visage du visage la ti visage mais
pas patiné un sas et aux îles à me
défoncer pourra disputer
ok non non non quand même pas que c'est
une blague et que je fais je détourne
ainsi si c'est fait exprès vous avez
bras
pour loin ça ressemble à ça mais vous
allez voir après ça va être exceptionnel
oui c'est là elle est bien celle là elle
est parfaite et monsieur la merci
d'accueillir maxence jackson sur scène
[Applaudissements]
incroyable exceptionnel tout rêve est
devenu réalité maxence merci c'est la
magie c'est la magie beau quoi d'autre
quoi d'autre c'était un peu facile j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être un donut au
chocolat as tu as tous les youtube a ri
et se retrouve phil quaife se lâche on à
youtube on annonce donne at il ya plus
qu à mixer les deux ça me donne faim mon
gars de détour est sage et archi faux
il est 13h 28e toujours pas manger sa
branche d'orgue en fait c'était prévu
depuis le début et ça il sert et que
j'ai pas mangé veux juste me mettre une
énorme dalle bien joué mon pote mais tu
feras moins malins quand on a une gueule
de donuts bon mais j'avoue que t'es pas
devenu un de notes mais t'es tu avais un
torticolis d'après ce qu'ils avaient
sous la main pour le pour le soigner
voilà désolé youtube c'est mon copain et
moi tu peux faire en sorte que ce soit
captain america sa place te plait merci
en vrai il a déjà tout de captain
america ton copain je dirais même que
c'est captain america mais quand il
n'est pas habillé en super héros du coup
pour qu'il trouve plus séduisant j'ai
juste à lui rajouter le masque de
captain america
et voilà on ne reconnaît comme c'est
comme un superman on le reconnaît plus d
qui la sonas ok t'es pas content j'ai
compris dans si tu veux je peux
éventuellement te rajoute et les yeux de
captain america
voilà tu trouves vraiment que ça le rend
plus beau tu trouves vraiment que
servant plus beau d'avoir un oeil de
travers alors aime ton copain commune et
arrête de fantasmer sur ce [ __ ] de
captain america officiel remanier plus
fort quoi d'autre quoi d'autre les
filous j'aimerais être chauve s'il te
plaît mais des tas de gens qui sont
choqués qu'ils aimeraient linverse mais
bon si tu veux tu veux donc un crâne
chauve pas de souci je trouve ça pépère
des chauves y en a partout mais qu'un y
compris sur google on va te mettre le
crâne chauve d'un mec qui fait des
shootings photos point un site de farces
et attrapes pas j'ai un peu de mal avec
ce secret ne pose des difficultés
non mais voilà je préfère vous le dire
mais ça à le faire ça le perse à le
faire
bon voici à quoi ressemblerait avec un
crâne chauve et des morceaux de décors
des retraites qui disparaissent on se
bat presque pas ma photo ci-bas pourquoi
cette y avait des cheveux à la place
avant et je sais pas trop comment
corriger donc j'ai fait de la merde on
sait pas on va faire un compromis mais
qu on va faire comment tu peux pas dire
je veux être chauve comme ça ça marche
pas comme ça il faut équilibrer si on
retire quelque chose au maire du coup
petites solutions que je te propose et
cheveux heroes ici tout simplement on ne
peut pas comme ça retirer ses choix ils
doivent aller quelque part il pressé
impossible sinon bon suivant deux mois
les totally spies
et oui avec ma fille avec du marc marc
flight bag j'ai faim [ __ ] ici une
vraie question se pose qui est quelle
fille moi je vais être sam ce que ça me
faisait un peu la sagesse c'est un peu
ce que je ne suis pas finalement un
voilà la raison c'est que j'étais
amoureux d'elle quand j'étais petit
j'étais fan complètement fan j'avais
envoyé des lettres et tous à tf1 pour
dire a dit hassan que je suis sam
ça c'est fait super aucun lit tout je
pense que lui c'est jerry en fait pas du
tout un tas c'est trop carlito ses
qualités au plus vieux mec très
clairement et en bien blanc parce qu'il
est proche de la mort aux rats tension
jerry en approche
carlito jerry bien sûr qui fait cette
tête parce qu'il se rend compte à ce
moment précis qu'il n'a pas de pectoraux
et voilà les totally spies
on n'est pas mal tôt ou tard lito
excellent abba mcfly rendu plus jeune
que toi ok ok je sais que votre âge vous
complique beaucoup on va tout de suite
régler ce problème ensemble
aujourd'hui ma foi j'ai retrouvé une
photo de toi quand tu étais bébé à
l'instant sur google se met pas de fly
bébé je tombais sur cette image voilà
carrément ressemblant à laure après un
dur travail mcfly et à ses fesses et bon
mc fly est devenu plus jeune que moi il
manque plus que carlito attention et bim
je crois que là les mecs je pouvais pas
faire mieux j'espère vous allez mieux
vivre votre cause et la trentaine grâce
à cette photo
en tout cas moi je me sens déjà vu en la
voyant cela faut que je l'imprimé que
l'afutt là ça c'est que ça dès que je
sortirai mal je les regarderai ça ira
mieux je veux des corps d'athlète
oh là là là là c'était mais ici on est
rattrapable ses deux garçons je pense
que c'est ça va être beaucoup plus
simple qu'il n'y paraît vous allez voir
celle là je vais mettre seulement 15
minutes à la faire au lieu de 36
bon je viens de travailler sur cette
photo alors vous pensiez que c'était un
faisable mais les amis regardez on va
passer d'accord
bon qui subit un peu la vie à des belles
tablettes de chocolat loi ce montage est
bien fait c'est le premier que j'arrive
à bien faire qu'est ce qui se passe mon
gars par contre pour ce qui est de son
camarade
franchement il est à ses muscles comme
ça je trouve qu'il ya pas grand chose à
modifier quoi alors on passe à autre
chose je veux que maurice mon chat me
prenne dans ses bras s'il te plaît mon
gars j'aimerais bien aussi que méchante
reine alors voir des fois qu'ils me
caresse qui me nourrissent etc
je vais te mettre bien mec j'ai réalisé
ce rêve les avis j'ai passé 20 minutes
sur cette photo pour un résultat
moyennement c'est disposant ouais c'est
pas c'est pas faux bond et voit la
division atlantique n'hésitez pas à
laisser vous a plu je sais pas si elle
sera courte ou pas mais je pense que oui
parce que je ne me doutais pas que ça
allait me prendre autant de temps de
photoshop et des images mais je ferai
plus jamais ça je perçois qu'en fait
j'ai quelques éléments à ce qu'ils de
merde je suis plus fort en géographique
en montage photo vous rendez compte ou
pas attention les miniatures je m'en
sors bien gardé là je m'en suis bien
sorti là je m'en suis bien sorti enfin
si je m'en sors quoi sur les miniatures
vite fait un peu aller on a quand même
fait six ou sept heureux aujourd'hui
avec ces montages merveilleux on a
exaucé des rêves et pour ça on peut être
fier de nous je veux dire devenir une
montgolfière c'est quand même une chance
et tout le monde n'a pas cette chance
à bientôt
[Musique]
où
ça